what's happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch brooklyn nine nine
another episode i hate watching this
show oh hit that like button if you like
this dumb show subscribe and click that
notification when you're notified when i
react for the next dumb episode is up
well full-length watch along just
sitting with the time code where we just
sit there bored out of my mind over our
patreon page we cover a bunch of shows
over there as well thanks super thumb
jaden one of you guys or a prep writing
these down you guys must fall asleep
every time you help us edit these saw
those comments people being like greg
you look upset or angry or just zoning
out and that is the last episode sorry
i'm not laugh track over here i'm gonna
laugh said every joke and reacts to
every joke that's right fake ass
in the biz wait watch things straight
face and then when something makes me
laugh i laugh audience sitcom
regular person at home
hbo showtime quality tv
over here
bs laugh track sitcom network tv you're
watching the big bang theory yeah
bazinga
anyway
[Music]
have a nice weekend peralta yeah nothing
special yeah you gotta come you missed
scully's birthday
oh nobody showed at the party we missed
scully's birthday and it was a big one i
know i panicked and said i had to go to
the vet because my puppy cat got sick i
said i had to take my mom to get birth
control pills
i told them i was in ecuador i think
they bought it we got to make it up to
him let's give him cash everyone put in
20 each uh yes i'll cover you
[Laughter]
we're sorry that we missed your party
well don't worry about it you all have
stuff to do yes the capital of ecuador
is quito oh
happy birthday from all of us did he
just con them
i can't believe it the fake birthday
work yeah
good call
whoa
[Music]
i've seen this episode before all right
then it's on me i'm ready to hate it now
this opens a creepy old wardrobe slash
portal to an enchanted land full of
talking toads and fairy folk interesting
[Music]
take it to the postal inspection service
see we can find out copy that
hey work this thing hard we're under a
lot of pressure with a task force so we
could really use a win you got it you're
my friend and i won't let you down i'm
gonna push you up just like a bra what
santiago i may need you to come in for a
bit on saturday again are you kidding me
man
just happened her mind finally snapped
like a stale bread stick
captain please forgive me
i'm just a little on edge because uh
i'm trying to quit smoking i can't take
this dress of hiding it from teddy
anymore you smoke oh
her secret vice
of course we'll do everything we can to
help or plan b i could arrange for you
to go to a safe place where you can just
relax and watch pretty boats go by
look this one's on an island
[Laughter]
cool guy probably expecting a cool knock
that was incredible enter
enter who is the guest star jack danger
it's actually pronounced donger
u.s postal inspection service founded by
benjamin franklin in 1772 undoubtedly
great man's greatest accomplishment are
you aware that he he'll popularize
parmesan cheese in america i am
[Laughter]
this sexy beast was used to open a type
of mailbox we actually haven't used in
years however there are a few around
town that were never removed
real buttes
hmm here my email is not
no email
oh no because email has put hundreds of
my co-workers out of work
how would you like it if they laid off
all of your fellow detectives and
partnered you with a robocop i've
literally drawn sketches of that
[Music]
no
but i did once have an addiction
food
it got bad
oh
i need more
i would dump my head into ice water and
reset my brain watch me
whoa
i'm all good
yeah you dry okay
[Laughter]
do it again
it's so cold it's really cold last time
[Laughter]
i uh try that please tell me i don't
have to keep working with that detective
peralta hi at us because everyone gets
his own office but that's because we're
this proud nation's first defense in the
war on terror every envelope is a
potential target for al-qaeda
[Laughter]
[Music]
take it away
would you talk to the falafel guy see if
you've seen anything suspicious uh you
should probably let me take lead on this
a lot of people don't like cops and
everybody loves postal workers they do
that's why the phrase most associated
with bringing goodness into people's
lives is going postal
[Laughter]
i know what it means
i just said what i mean that's what it
means
oh no
jackpot
it's giggle pig yes
you have served your country proud
little lady
oh no
goodness
oh
you okay no i'm rattled
damn you at helms oh i myself overcame
an addiction i could not get enough of
the ponies go razzmatazz
go rasmus
i lost everything
grab your sneaker santiago you're
joining me on a lunchtime job
great we could talk a little chat about
the job do some mentor mentee bonding we
will exercise in silence
no headphones either
music is a crutch
the ground level obstruction was your
hand clutching my leg i have claw marks
all over my calf
i'm sorry rosa can i talk to you in
private for a second yep we'll be right
back boyle why don't you show donger
what a fax machine is
oh
okay imagine a letter had unprotected
sex with a phone
[Laughter]
look these dealers didn't just randomly
start using mailbox keys there's clearly
a postal connection sorry dude you got
to keep working with him okay wait wait
wait wait wait maybe is the connection
but if he tells me one more time about
how husbands mailed down the berlin wall
i'm gonna give him your home address and
you will receive holiday cards from him
forever my own relatives don't have that
address oh i know
i know
look at them shorts balloon thighs
yeah listen i gotta jump in there
hello kevin
no i haven't seen him
i very much doubt that why would the
housekeeper steal your build
oh
santiago are you smoking in there no
why do i see smoke that's steam i'm in
the shower
that's the guy from this morning nypd
open up all right i'm gonna break down
the door no let me do it charles that's
never gone well yes but i've been
practicing all right fine you get one
try thank you
nice good roll too
yes that's the bad guy yup yup
what's going on is this a dream
no i'm not holding a label maker
[Laughter]
i am a powerful woman for i am a
powerful woman i'm not hearing everyone
for i am a powerful woman
[Laughter]
gently caressing your face i feel it
i feel the breeze amy
donger just called and said you
abandoned him took information from a
classified computer and licked a roll of
antique stamps the stamps were on me i
was curious about how old glue tasted
answer like a horse lollipop
okay
glue
dongle's furious he's on his way over
here now because they're taking over the
case what he can't do that yeah he can
they're a federal agency goddamn i'm
sorry i was a jerk
i'm sorry i said the postman was a flop
[Laughter]
i don't think you're sorry and i don't
think you respect uspis maybe at first
but that was before i read
stamping out crime a history of the
espans
great read
the real story begins in the 16th
century with la postes
yes
two seven eight eight nine that's
washington north carolina eight zero
seven five one that's
sterling colorado
sterling place on washington avenue wait
a minute mr postman
before we go in there apology accepted
no i actually want to do it so i have to
suffer i'll make it quick
took advantage of our friendship i was a
jerk i'm sorry
so that's what eternity feels like
[Laughter]
tag team one will take the north
entrance tech team two will take the
east door jake you stay out here and man
the radio oh
sure whatever you need on it yeah i'm
just kidding you coming in with us
[Music]
wow what happened
all right another win for us
you're lying in rat turds it's all part
of the job little brother it's all part
of the job not a dog
yes
i hate this show yeah lap track mcgee
sad zoning out the whole time ah
i just laughed when i knew there was a
joke i didn't actually listen to
anything all right
all right well that was good
so i'm gonna say all right whatever
finds the d light
it's fine
afternoon delight
boom
you know john when i put this we have
this camera plugged in
to the computer so we can see um you
know like if we're in frame and stuff
whenever it's in front of us john just
looks at himself the whole time when
we're talking looking at you
when you're talking you're looking at me
uh actually i'm looking at neither of us
really it's more just like the box
just look at it
it's my
it's not me or you so much as it's just
the kind of color square
that this is it's just like it's moving
because we're moving and it's colorful
because this whole set is freaking
colorful and busy and
you know
it's great it's never change it unless
you move and then you know update it and
we'll change it
and on all sincerity
um
that was that was great every storyline
worked really well yeah
i can't relate at all with what amy was
going through
not you
not me who's always not puffing in here
never that's my cigarette
never times when we're sitting down to
film and it's like we gotta clear the
smoke out of the room
can you tell the light's catching it
ah man the smoking cigarette days were
worse yes it's much more pleasant now
because you know you get good smelling
juices
before whereas before it was just
regular cigarettes
i would smoke indoors smoking doors and
you would try and blow it out the window
but it was still diffused throughout the
entire place best part was when a guest
would come over who was also a smoker oh
he didn't date smoking we could smoke
inside this stinkle yeah yeah and me
over here my allergies like hey guys
it's great
you know
it's tough quitting i still i'm still in
the throwing the e-cigarette installing
these upgrades of this cat right here
but didn't you go down didn't you like
knock down your nicotine levels to like
the minimum or to nothing i'm on three
three three half of zero
okay so i get it man it's tough it's a
tough prospect it's really hard to quit
you just get this being alright craving
are you getting like right here in the
back of my teeth ooh
the longest i go when i'm awake while
not smoking is if i'm in a theater
okay but then about an hour and i'm like
i can't wait to go outside and puff that
easier
matter of fact i really wanna do it
right now i'm not going to lie do it
do it break all the rules pull the
curtain back no reveal your hidden
addiction that's not so hidden
i thought her performance was great i
forgot she smells is that established
that she smokes i don't i don't remember
that yeah i believe so it's not a thread
that comes up a lot but it is a thread
that they have at least established of
her i feel like peralta at some point
catches her on the like roof or
something smoking at one point and that
establishes it
buddy buddy smoking what did he what he
said something during the review dude
was that him i thought olivia was in
here yeah he came in and did like a
round
i thought olivia was like saying
something sounded like an actual word
yeah i was like what is that here was
that an error in the video
what was going on
it's like a random stray piece of like
background dialogue that got mixed way
too high that's what it sounded like at
first yeah no just watch buddy you can't
lick the plastic if we try to do these
in one
one
this is your addiction you got to get
them off the plastic you got to get them
off the glue we try to do these without
cutting watson get them off the horse
lollipops so complicated
look at him just going for it just plain
boxes and plastic you can't have the
plastic you just threw up in here i feel
like we need to b-roll with watson oh my
goodness doing his thing over here
um ed helms is so good
ed helms is so good at being like a
cocky
cocky arrogant d-bag he's incredible at
it that's the point where i didn't even
see at helms anymore
which is funny
why because he's funny
yes no continue
don't know why well it's funny because
because that is a character he plays so
much and it's like the guy who is a
cocky arrogant d-bag who is also kind of
lame yeah and i feel like he owns that
character but you're right like he did
kind of just blend into it here and it
he brings different shades to it sure
i thought it was
fascinating because yeah first you see
me like it's ed helms doing ed helms bit
that adhems does yeah then after a while
i was like man this guy is so
frustrating what
helms is annoying it was like man this
is characters yeah you feel the
frustration
yeah when he first clings on to
peralta's leg you're just like oh dude
oh god
god damn it man and then he blames him
after yeah
well that was really funny i didn't know
anything about it i didn't realize you
was supposed to have you that was
his federal agency die yeah i didn't
know that
i thought they were just a broke
business no
i mean that's i guess that's the thing
is it wasn't there that part of the
issue of like you know should we should
we do you know your tax dollars be
funding the post office when there are
things like fedex and ups that are
private you know yeah
and uh yeah that's fair fair point yeah
it said it's an arm of the gov i don't
know the u.s post office man i love him
half the time i get mail i throw half of
it out i throw a lot of mail away maybe
90 of my mail i i yeah you know you get
those credit card offers you get those
like flyers for coupons i get all my uh
paper billing that i also get online
billing for and then i pay it online and
i'm going why do i keep getting paper
bills no matter how many times you
select only the online statement
that's how you still keep getting
married here's all your physical copies
is that it you want to use paper
rosa man i like a stern woman yeah and i
love that that threat has continued that
was another one where i had to be like
oh that's right she did get promoted to
the head of this particular task force
and that brings out a certain shade of
her character where like she does yeah
put on the authority and the leader the
captain role yeah and i love seeing her
in that place
who plays amy what's her name melissa
fumero
i wonder if she smokes in real life her
skin looks amazing
well you know she probably like you know
has a thing she can do to
you know keep the smoke from wafting
back on to her perfect complexion
i mean it's also internal
gee not when you got modern advancements
in beauty maintenance yeah man
those are some funny ass bits meditating
help me slow down
for sure
exercise i did all those things exercise
running duck my head
you are a perfect amalgam of every
method displayed across this episode
well tony robbins actually says that one
thing he does is he
um immerses himself in like ice cold
water like 50 degrees every morning
because changing up the physiolog
physiology of your body
is a part of that like those are aspects
of defeating addiction too
yeah that makes sense i i can
see you know what times are just in here
and it's boring and you just gotta edit
and smoke some music
yeah you know it's especially hard in
those moments where time is expanding
and crawling on and you're stuck in one
place and you just want a little bit of
an oasis yeah yeah
i hear you
anyway it's one of coffee another really
funny episode from brooklyn nine nine
leave your thoughts down below and a
great cold open
great cold open too
he's making a pun nope i thought that
cold open was
especially funny
the con artist
good good to see
scully almost win yeah
hey guys so
jn valente if it was up to me i would
love to do all the things to you that
get done to amy in this episode i think
it'd be so fun to dunk your head in a
bucket full of ice water watching you in
there with your crazy ass thought
process
i wonder what your brain would be
thinking during that time i'd also love
to go on a run with you
seeing you run away as if the devil's
horses are chasing after you just
knowing how sporadic your mind works
you'd probably think satan sent his
minions after you and it would be an
enjoyable time
and i'd love to meditate with you i
think you'd probably be one of the most
frustrating people to have a meditation
session with
you probably just keep opening your eyes
saying i can't do this i cancel my
thoughts down and i'd be like jay and
it's not about
stopping thoughts about just slowing
down it's being aware and then you would
go into some existential speech
again
and i'd be like this is pointless here's
a cigarette and beer i quit i give up on
you and then you go that's what real
friends are for
so j.n
i hope we have a good time this coming
thanksgiving where you and i
indulge ourselves in some filthy habits
terrible habits
i'm talking
strippers and not the good kind of
strippers
the stinky ones
yeah
in the back page of the deli weekly
looking at the stinky strippers
stinky strippers
[Music]